and now one of the political world's
most well-known
oracles the american pollster and
communications
strategist frank luntz is best known for
his analysis of american politics
he hit the headlines earlier this year
when he declared that he'd had enough of
donald trump and the republican party
but he's always retained a keen interest
in uk politics too
ever since advising boris johnson on his
campaign for the presidency of the
oxford union
35 years ago now luntz has undertaken
the survey of this nation for the centre
for policy studies
focusing on language and attitudes
towards political
and economic issues and is here to
discuss those findings ahead of the
survey's
full publication later this week frank
luds
what were you actually trying to
understand with this survey
well in three words populism woke-ism
and extremism i've seen the damage
that's done to american politics to the
american economy
and i want to see that happen here in
the uk i spent three years at oxford in
the 1980s
i was recently a lecturer for a week at
the vlavotnick institute at oxford
and i loved it i really do love it here
and i appreciate the civility and the
decency that people
exhibit i appreciate the respect that
they have for different points of view
and it's in essence a warning a wake-up
call
and and a road map for how to avoid
the mess that we've got in america right
now and i say this on the fourth of july
and it really disappoints me
because i still love my country and i'm
still
i'm still patriotic i still get
emotional when i see the flag
but i get emotional when i see your flag
as well the union jack
and i want to see understanding i want
to see respect i want to see civility
across the political spectrum
so that's why i'm here and that's the
purpose of the cps study
well we were talking earlier on the
program about that issue and we just had
a by-election i think you'll know here
where uh i have to say it wasn't
particularly
um characterized by civility but let's
have a look at the whole picture
let's start with what people think about
um
political leaders in britain you ask a
question about how political leaders
make people feel
look at that that's the number one
answer we gave them a list of 18
attributes and disappointed came in
first ignored irrelevant
the first eight words we gave them ten
negative words and eight positive words
and the first eight that they chose were
all negative
that this is a wake-up call for the
conservatives for lib dems for labor for
the greens it's a wake-up call for
everyone in politics
that the public isn't hearing you that
you may be
speaking you may be doing events you may
be sending them emails and text you may
have a website
but to them it's all noise you need to
cut through the clutter and i'm going to
give you three
recommendations for it number one is
that they want to know what you are for
not what you are against so don't define
yourself by the other party define
yourself
by yours number two the highest priority
right now
is honesty and trust so be candid with
them say what you mean and mean what you
say
and number three safety security
strong uh successful that the number one
focus
is still the economy but number two
right underneath it and right behind it
is crime
so give people a better quality of life
and they'll give you
a re-election that's um
well that's that's quite a big steer for
us as a program this
sounds like we'd um do better in ratings
if we had fewer politicians on
bit of a problem for us but the the
point you make there about division
which we again we discussed earlier on
um in the united states we see a lot of
division on the
issues of race and so on uh is that
reflected here what's the greatest
divide that we're seeing in britain
today
the number one divide is by wealth it's
by
income inequality we've got the same
challenge in the states even the
conservatives
who talk about economic freedom even
they
prioritize rich versus poor as
uh as the number two behind uh british
born versus
immigrant but overall the rich versus
poor
divine and by the way this is a warning
for the conservatives
that they need to understand and reflect
the public's feeling that nobody
succeeds
if everyone doesn't succeed that this
idea of every and all
is essential every person needs a shot
at success every person in every
community
needs a shot and a ladder up the
opportunity to succeed
it's not the definition of what happens
at the end that matters
they're not asking for equal outcomes
which is
a labor challenge but they are asking
for equal opportunity they're asking for
a healthy economy
an open economy and they're asking that
they be respected
as hard-working taxpayers that's
interesting
because um you know that's clear and
that's a traditional
divide in this country but we hear a lot
of noise about what
people these days call culture wars the
issues
of race of uh religion religion and
religious fundamentalism and all of that
and um this relatively new word which
other surveys recently here suggests
nobody really
or most people don't really know what it
means wokism what what
are we following america in our
obsession with that or is it something
it's not going to matter to us
i think it's going to matter deeply it
doesn't matter right now but it's coming
there are many ways that america follows
the uk
uh your vote from prexa was an
indication of a hidden vote
that that donald trump took advantage of
your vote for margaret thatcher back 40
years ago
was the leading indicator for ronald
reagan and there are times when america
is ahead of you such as bill clinton to
tony blair and right now
woke-ism cancel culture uh
the the language is mean and harsh
and the outcome will be negative as as
you've got right up there the
conservatives are deeply afraid of
rocism
labor is more afraid of racism even
though
third of your country does not know what
locism is it's still the number three
consumer
the number three ism and here's why they
know that it's divisive they know that
it's polarizing they know that it's not
being put
forward to have a better more unified
country which is what the
cps study is all about it's about unity
woke-ism is about division about
polarization about punishing people for
success
and not respecting hard work and
meritocracy and by the way i don't know
if you've got this data
but to my surprise people put equality
over meritocracy now i need to give a
proviso
inequality is unacceptable in 2021 uk
and 2021 u.s
equality a discrimination
that we expect everyone everywhere to
have that opportunity
and we want that opportunity to be
available to everyone based on hard work
creativity and outcome so
i would think that we would want to
cherish meritocracy but right now
equality is a higher priority to the
british population
one of the um that's interesting one of
the outputs of the
if you like this the concern about these
issues of workers and so on is
what's called cancel culture i people's
essentially having the right to free
expression deprived
um what what do we think about that we
think that freedom of speech is the
number one
freedom we believe that freedom of
speech freedom of expression
so nobody wants to cancel rallies nobody
wants to limit
protests it's a very very small
percentage
of the uk population but they want to
ensure
that those who work hard play by the
rules pay their
taxes that they're respected not
punished
and you'll see a big difference between
conservative voters and labor voters
on this issue of cancer culture and in
fact on every issue
we have a divide in america uh
personally and the way we treat each
other
that divide is not as great in the uk
however
the uk political policy divisions
priority divisions
are even wider than the us and i will
tell you from personal experience here
on the fourth of july on a day
that i should be celebrating by going to
fireworks and having burgers and
and uh coleslaw and and just celebrating
independence
it's very hard to celebrate because we
are so mean
and so ugly and so rotten to each other
the language that we would not
accept our kids using is language that
politicians use against each other every
day in america
and they don't want to see that in the
uk we've been conducting focus groups of
cps and
and the response is people are
respectful and decent
and disagree with each other in a
positive way that's the kind of politics
you want to practice
that's the kind of politics we should be
doing in america
and i want to ensure that that kind of
politics stays in the uk forever
uh i want you to say it on on
independence day but maybe the
the brits have something to teach the
americans about being nice and
and civil uh but by the way one one um
of the results which i thought was very
interesting
is that we don't just have a low opinion
of politicians but also to some extent
of british
uh of business leaders um and there's a
i think we've got a
result about what we think business
leaders ought to be doing
yes and the one thing that's a shock to
me is that
climate in this country is now universal
that this is the only country where
arguably more people on the right are
environmentalists
and are focused on issues of climate
than people on the left
it's not happening anywhere else in the
globe but it is happening here
this is the one area where universally
the british public says let's be
environmentally friendly
let's have a cleaner safer healthier
globe
let's put our environmental community
first
it's very impressive to see i thought
it's really interesting that actually
conservatives appear to be marginally
more concerned about business leaders
doing something on climate change than
uh labor supporters yeah but you know
where we got universal agreement
the business community should stay out
of politics
they want business to focus on business
focus on employees focus on
their employees not workers and by the
way they're no longer businesses they're
employers
because the british public is so much
more supportive of those
who who create jobs than they are of
that company itself
and they want customers they want to
focus
on on employees and not
on shareholders and what's interesting
is investor
is so much more supported than a
shareholder because a shareholder
is just about making money and investors
making a personal commitment
in that in that business and that
employer and in the future
so we have a whole business lexicon
that'll be helpful
to uh to those involved in the british
economy and believe me
they need to use it because right now
the business community also
has some credibility issues frank you
need to spend more time with us we are
basically so nice and lovely and polite
on this side of
the water um and be good to see more of
you
i don't want to go home i want to stay
here but uh i need to leave in a few
weeks but
thank you once again even your interview
on sky
is more civil than what we have in the
u.s so i appreciate it